Всім нам потрібна можливість передавати приватну інформацію без страху, що хтось підслуховує. Але розробити
надійну систему для цього непросто. У сьогоднішньому випуску Qiskit in the Classroom ми поговоримо про те, як
так зване квантове розподілення ключів може
допомогти. Ласкаво повертайтесь до Qiskit in the Classroom. У цій серії ми розглянемо теми, з якими ти можеш зустрітися в університетському курсі,
пов'язаному з квантовими обчисленнями. До кожного відео є інтерактивний модуль із посиланням в описі, тож
обов'язково перевір його. Сьогодні ми заглибимось у світ квантової криптографії. Криптографія — це вивчення
методів захищеного зв'язку. Це надзвичайно важливо для багатьох сфер нашого життя. Кожного разу, коли ти використовуєш
пароль для входу на сайт, надсилаєш цифровий платіж або коли уряди передають військову розвідку — все це робиться
через якийсь криптографічний протокол, щоб підслухувач не міг дізнатися наших секретів. Але тут є суперечність. Як
нам переконатися, що та людина, з якою ми хочемо спілкуватися, зрозуміє наше повідомлення, але ніхто інший не зможе?
Історично криптографи розробили багато різних протоколів, щоб зробити свої повідомлення якомога більш захищеними
від підслуховувачів. Іноді дві сторони, які хочуть спілкуватися безпечно, заздалегідь домовляються про певний
код, який, як вони сподіваються, настільки складний, що підслухувач не зможе його зламати. Але як
показали такі люди, як Alan Turing та інші зламувачі шифрів воєнного часу, навіть найскладніші коди можна
зламати. В ідеалі ми хотіли б надсилати повідомлення, зашифровані так, щоб у них абсолютно не було жодного шаблону
і жодного способу, яким підслухувач міг би їх зрозуміти, не маючи також таємного випадкового ключа, відомого лише відправнику та
одержувачу. Але тоді ми відкриваємо себе для нової вразливості. Як нам надіслати цей ключ і бути впевненими, що
ніхто його не перехопить? У 1984 році Charles Bennett і Jill Brassard придумали
метод безпечного надсилання ключа за допомогою квантових бітів, який тепер називається BB84. Ключова особливість цих квантових
бітів або qubit'ів, що робить можливим цей протокол, полягає в тому, що вони підкоряються принципу невизначеності. Не можна виміряти
квантову систему, не порушивши її. Сьогодні ми почнемо з прикладу простого криптографічного коду. Потім я
покажу тобі, як квантове розподілення ключів і принцип невизначеності дозволяють нам використовувати майже нерозшифровувані
шифрування. Я детально поясню тобі протокол BB84, і нарешті ми запустимо його на справжньому квантовому
комп'ютері. Спочатку почнемо з гри, яку ти, можливо, вже бачив — вона називається криптограма.
Тобі дається послідовність буквів, які здаються випадковими, але використовуючи свої знання про шаблони в англійській
мові, ти можеш замінити одну букву іншою, щоб зрозуміти зміст повідомлення. Ось приклад. Це
таємне повідомлення з простим шифром підстановки. Тож усі літери R представляють одну букву, M — іншу,
і так далі. Якщо хочеш спробувати розгадати це самостійно, постав відео на паузу зараз.
Виявляється, це повідомлення було зашифровано дуже простим шифром — шифром Цезаря, де
алфавіт просто зсунуто на певну кількість позицій — у цьому випадку на 9. Тож A стає J, B
стає K, C стає L і так далі. Чим довше повідомлення, тим легше
побачити шаблон. Тож із повідомленням такої довжини, як те, що нам дано, шифр Цезаря або будь-який інший шифр, який просто
замінює одну букву алфавіту на іншу, досить легко зламати. Більш безпечний спосіб закодувати таємне
повідомлення — це так званий одноразовий блокнот. З одноразовим блокнотом ти можеш мати різний зсув для кожної букви в
повідомленні. Тобі просто потрібно повідомити своєму другу, який був зсув для кожної, щоб він міг розшифрувати повідомлення.
Цей список зсувів називається ключем або блокнотом. Він називається одноразовим блокнотом, бо використовується один раз, а потім викидається.
Якщо використовувати його більше одного разу, з'являться шаблони, які можуть зробити шифрування зламаним. При
шифруванні одноразовим блокнотом і зашифроване повідомлення, і ключ окремо — це просто випадковий рядок безглуздих символів. Але
якщо поєднати їх разом, ти побачиш, як з шуму виникає таємне повідомлення.
Розглянемо короткий приклад. Скажімо, я вже створив і надіслав своєму другу цей одноразовий блокнот, який зазвичай записується в
двійковому вигляді. А потім я хочу надіслати повідомлення "I love quantum". Тоді я б закодував повідомлення
за допомогою одноразового блокнота ось так. Спочатку ми конвертуємо букви нашого повідомлення в двійковий формат. Кожна буква від A до Z буде
відповідати числам від 1 до 26, записаним у двійковому форматі. Тож A буде 0 0
0 1, B — 0 0 1
0, C — 0 0 1 1 і так
далі. А пробіл буде просто самими нулями.
Ось у що перетворюється повідомлення. Ми кодуємо повідомлення, виконуючи XOR між кожним бітом повідомлення та
відповідним бітом одноразового блокнота. Якщо ти раніше не зустрічав XOR,
це скорочення від "exclusive or" (виключне або). XOR між двома бітами дорівнює одиниці, якщо тільки один
із бітів дорівнює одиниці, і нулю, якщо обидва нульові або обидва одиничні. Тож перший набір із п'яти бітів у закодованому
повідомленні стає 1 0
0 1 1. Решту XOR'ів залишаю тобі зробити самостійно. Але суть у тому, що
це повідомлення тепер є просто випадковим рядком нулів і одиниць без жодного шаблону. Воно абсолютно нечитабельне для будь-кого, хто
не має одноразового блокнота, який ми використали для шифрування повідомлення. Отже, що ми дізналися до цього часу? Деякі схеми шифрування
кращі за інші, і деякі може вгадати розумна людина, шукаючи шаблони в зашифрованому
повідомленні. Але справді випадковий ключ, який зсуває кожну букву таємного повідомлення на різну випадкову величину, не можна
вгадати, бо в повідомленні немає жодних шаблонів. Єдина вразливість у такій схемі — переконатися,
що ключ, використаний для шифрування повідомлення, не потрапить у чужі руки. Ось тут і з'являється квантове
розподілення ключів. Використовуючи qubit'и, Bennett і Brassard придумали спосіб для двох сторін погодити ключ і
бути достатньо впевненими, що третя сторона таємно не підслуховувала. Цей протокол BB84 трохи складний, але
ми пройдемо його крок за кроком. Для цього пояснення повернемо наших старих знайомих — Alice і
Bob. Протокол починається з того, що Alice готує набір qubit'ів для надсилання Bob'у. Ці qubit'и містять
інформацію, яка стане їхнім спільним одноразовим блокнотом або ключем. Alice спочатку генерує дві випадкові послідовності
однакової довжини. Одна — це випадкова послідовність нулів і одиниць, а інша — випадкова послідовність X'ів і Z'ів, що представляють
базис, в якому вона підготує свої qubit'и. Потім вона підготує кожен qubit у квантовому стані відповідно до
комбінації базису та значення біта, показаної в цій таблиці. Тож якщо біт нульовий і базис — Z, вона
підготує qubit у нульовому стані. Або якщо біт одиничний і базис — X, вона підготує його в стані мінус. Якщо
ти не впевнений, що це за базиси і квантові стани — нічого страшного. Головне, що тобі потрібно знати, це те, що
вимірювання в кожному базисі завжди мають лише два можливі результати: 0 або 1 для Z-базису і плюс або мінус для X-
базису. Якщо виміряти стан нуль у Z-базисі, ти завжди отримаєш нуль.
Але якщо виміряти той самий стан у X-базисі, отримаєш випадковий результат — або плюс, або мінус, кожен з імовірністю 50%.
Отже, Alice може підготувати рядок qubit'ів ось так, де тут є випадковий рядок
нулів і одиниць, а тут — випадковий рядок X'ів і Z'ів. Тож перший елемент кожної з її
двох послідовностей — 0 і X. Це означає, що вона підготує перший qubit у стані плюс і так
далі. Після того як вона підготує всі стани qubit'ів, Alice надішле Bob'у ці qubit'и, і Bob випадково вибиратиме між X
та Z як базис для вимірювання кожного. Тож тепер ми додаємо кілька рядків до
таблиці, щоб відобразити вибір Bob'а і його вимірювання. Ось вибір Bob'а і
його вимірювання. А ось результати його вимірювань qubit'ів, які надіслала йому Alice. Нарешті, Bob
може конвертувати кожне вимірювання в біт, використовуючи ту саму таблицю, яку Alice використовувала для підготовки своїх qubit'ів. Коли він вимірює
стан нуль або плюс, він присвоює бітове значення нуль. А коли вимірює стан один або мінус — ставить
одиницю. Тож фінальний бітовий рядок Bob'а — це цей останній рядок.
Зверни увагу: коли базиси підготовки Alice та вимірювання Bob'а збігаються, то й їхні біти збігатимуться
теж. Але якщо Alice обирає підготовку в Z, а Bob вимірює в X, або навпаки,
то відповідні біти Alice і Bob'а не обов'язково будуть однаковими. Тож спосіб, яким вони обидва можуть погодити бітовий рядок
для свого одноразового блокнота, — це зателефонувати одне одному і сказати, який базис вони використовували для кожного qubit'а.
Коли базиси збігаються — вони залишають біт, коли ні — викидають його.
Отже, у цьому випадку Alice і Bob погодять бітовий рядок 0 0 1 0
0. Як ця схема захищає від непомічених підслуховувачів? Ну, давай подивимося, що відбувається, коли такий підслухувач
на ім'я Eve перехоплює qubit'и, які Alice надсилає Bob'у. Вона не знає, в якому стані ці qubit'и або як
Alice їх підготувала. Тож, завдяки принципу невизначеності і чомусь, що називається теоремою про заборону клонування, вона не може
просто зробити ідентичну копію qubit'ів, щоб передати їх Bob'у. Якби могла, то вона б змогла
підслуховувати непоміченою. Натомість вона вгадує базис, в якому виміряти кожен qubit, вимірює їх, а потім
готує новий набір підроблених qubit'ів для надсилання Bob'у. Є й інші, хитріші способи, якими Eve могла б спробувати
дізнатися про qubit'и, але жоден з них не обходить принцип невизначеності.
Тож ми просто припустимо цей прямолінійний метод підслуховування Eve. Ось таблиця, що описує
підготовку Alice, перехоплення Eve та фінальне вимірювання Bob'а. Отже, тепер коли
Alice і Bob розмовляють по телефону для порівняння своїх базисів, вони вирішать залишити ці біти для свого ключа, але
біти не збігаються. Це тому, що Bob вимірював qubit'и, підготовлені Eve, а не оригінальні qubit'и, які мала Alice.
Якщо вони порівняють підмножину бітів у своїх бітових рядках між собою, побачать, що деякі не збігаються, і
припустять, що мав бути підслухувач. Тож оскільки Eve була виявлена, Alice і Bob
викинуть свої бітові рядки і почнуть протокол спочатку. Але якби Eve не підслуховувала і підмножина
бітів, які порівняли Alice і Bob, збіглася, то вони могли б сміливо використовувати решту бітів, які вони не
порівнювали, як свій спільний ключ. Як тільки Alice і Bob мають спільний ключ, Alice може надсилати зашифровані повідомлення Bob'у, і
тільки Bob може їх розшифрувати за допомогою ключа. Тепер, коли ми пройшли протокол, давай спробуємо запустити його на
квантовому комп'ютері. Є кілька речей, які треба мати на увазі для цього експерименту. По-перше,
BB84 справді корисний лише тоді, коли Alice і Bob знаходяться далеко один від одного. Для експерименту, який ми збираємося провести, Alice
і Bob знаходяться на одному квантовому чипі. Тож цей експеримент не буде корисним для обміну приватною інформацією, але це
все одно хороша концептуальна демонстрація BB84.
По-друге, справжні квантові комп'ютери мають шуми. Тож навіть якщо базис підготовки Alice збігається з базисом вимірювання Bob'а
і підслухувача не було, все одно є невеликий шанс, що вони виміряють різні біти через помилки в
квантовому комп'ютері. Коли вони порівнюють свої бітові рядки для перевірки підслуховувачів, їм потрібно мати певний допуск до помилок, перш ніж вони
вирішать, що підслухувач точно втручався, і викинуть весь ключ. Тепер, з урахуванням цих застережень,
почнемо з експерименту без підслухувача. Спочатку ми випадково
генеруємо три різних бітових рядки, кожен по 20 бітів. Перший — це початковий бітовий рядок
Alice. Другий — це список базисів, в яких Alice підготує свої qubit'и.
Тут ми обрали нуль для представлення Z-базису і одиницю для X-базису. Фінальний список — це базиси,
в яких Bob вимірюватиме кожен qubit. На основі цих трьох списків ми можемо скласти схему circuit з інструкціями для
підготовки Alice та вимірювань Bob'а. Всі qubit'и починають у нульовому стані. Тож щоб підготувати свої qubit'и в
Z-базисі, Alice або нічого не робить для нульового стану, або застосовує gate NOT або X, показаний як сині блоки з позначкою X
для одиничного стану. Для підготовки в X-базисі вона застосовує або gate Hadamard, який переводить нуль у стан плюс,
або gate NOT, за яким слідує Hadamard, щоб підготувати стан мінус. Потім вона надсилає qubit'и Bob'у. Наступний набір блоків
у circuit представляє вимірювання Bob'а. Щоб виміряти в Z-базисі, йому не потрібно застосовувати більше gate'ів.
Він просто вимірює, що показано цими сірими блоками. Щоб виміряти в X-базисі, він спочатку застосовує Hadamard і
потім вимірює. Ми запустимо цей circuit за допомогою примітиву sampler Qiskit runtime. А результатом є бітовий рядок
вимірювань Bob'а. Потім ми можемо порівняти бітові рядки Bob'а з початковим бітовим рядком Alice, викидаючи біти,
де їхні базиси не збіглися. І бачимо, що вони обидва отримують однаковий ключ.
Пам'ятай, це реальне залізо, тому час від часу може трапитися біт, який мав би збігатися, але не збігається. У цьому випадку всі
біти збіглися, але якщо запустиш це знову самостійно, може трапитися помилка, але поки вірність близька до одиниці,
Alice і Bob можуть бути достатньо впевнені, що підслухувача не було. Тепер подивимося, що відбувається, якщо Eve перехоплює
qubit'и. Тепер у нас два circuit'и. Перший показує підготовку Alice та перехоплення і
вимірювання Eve. Наступний показує підготовку Eve підроблених qubit'ів та вимірювання Bob'а. Ми
можемо запустити ці circuit'и як і раніше, а потім подивитися, що отримають Alice і Bob, коли порівняють свої бітові
рядки. Цього разу вони отримують вірність 0.6 з повторенням. Це набагато нижче, ніж те, що
можна пояснити шумом квантового комп'ютера. Тож вони роблять висновок, що Eve підслуховувала. Квантові обчислення
широко відомі і часто рекламуються через свій потенціал вирішувати складні завдання. Але квантовий зв'язок і криптографія
часто отримують набагато менше уваги, хоча потенціал, який квантові технології можуть запропонувати в цих областях, є настільки ж
значущим і захоплюючим. Сьогодні ми обговорили найперший відкритий протокол квантового розподілення ключів, який
практично захищений від непоміченого підслуховування. Якщо хочеш спробувати надіслати нерозшифровуваний код із
квантово-сертифікованим ключем, переходь до модуля за посиланням в описі.
Дякую за перегляд, і побачимося наступного разу.